Hey Wisecrack, Jared here, and today we’re
talking about the smart and stylish JRPG that
lets you simultaneously date your high school
teacher, your middle school-aged step-sister,
and an alcoholic Lois Lane: Persona 5.
For those of you who’ve never played Persona
5, we recommend pausing this video and playing
through the 120 hour campaign.
But if you don’t have that much time, we’ll
summarize it for you.
The Persona series is basically what you’d
get if a group of otaku made a Pokemon clone
set in the world of Inside Out.
You spend half the game in a high school social
management simulator, and the other half as
a superhero gentleman thief that enters people’s
cognitions in order to catch ‘em all, albeit
instead of Pikachus you’re nabbing mythological
monsters, gods, heroes, historical figures,
and characters from literature - including
whatever the hell this is.
Going by the codename Joker, you slowly assemble
a crew called the Phantom Thieves of Hearts
to heist the innermost desires from the most
powerful and corrupt adults in society.
- “You sons of bitches - what’s the job?”
So let’s look at whether the aspects of
Persona which people praise so often are actually
Deep or Dumb.
Spoilers ahead for the original game, but
not for the expanded Persona 5 Royal which
won’t be available state side until the end of March.
Part 1 - Jungian Psychology
Carl Jung was the founder of analytical psychology.
Just as his colleague Sigmund Freud invented
an entire vocabulary for psychoanalysis, Jung
coined terms like archetype, shadow, persona,
and the collective unconscious and the series
cites its Jungian influences explicitly.
In Persona 4 Golden, you can unlock new episodes
of Mr. Edogawa's TV Classroom, which are straight
up lectures about Jungian psychology.
But the primary place you encounter these
Jungian terms is during the combat sections.
When our regular high schoolers enter the
Metaverse, they transform into personas that
are dramatizations of the Jungian concept
much in the same way as Joy and Anger in Inside
Out are dramatizations of emotions.
Really, the whole world of Persona is a dramatization
of Jung’s ideas about the human psyche.
Take the Metaverse, a world created by human
cognition that the Phantom Thieves are capable
of entering.
The Metaverse is representative of all psychological
activity, collective and individual, conscience
and unconscious.
Some parts, called Palaces, represent an individual’s
mental activity, specifically their distorted
perspective of a place in the real world.
Take the girl’s volleyball coach, Kamoshida.
He’s got such a high opinion of his status
at Shujin Academy that he envisions it as
a castle, ruled by him as its king.
Other parts, such as Mementos, are how society
as a whole sees the world around it, and given
the deep cynicism of the day, it’s not a
pleasant place.
This shared psychic space of society, along
with the Sea of Souls from which all Shadows
and Personas emerge, are dramatizations of
a Jungian concept called the Collective Unconscious.
It’s those parts of the mind that we inherited
from our most remote ancestors, like fight
or flight.
But it also includes what Jung described as
“pre-existent forms, the archetypes... which
give definite form to certain psychic contents.”
Of the innumerable archetypes within the Collective
Unconscious, Jung considered four to be primordial,
the most basic and universal images, among
which are the Persona and the Shadow.
Personas are social masks that the Ego chooses
to wear.
Jung himself described them as “designed
on the one hand to make a definite impression
upon others, and, on the other, to conceal
the true nature of the individual.”
In Latin, persona refers to the masks worn
by actors.
In the game, whenever they enter the Metaverse,
the Phantom Thieves quite literally wear their
Personas as masks.
Per Jung, the Thieves’ Personas are how
they want society to see them, and how they
want to see themselves.
Take Ann, who is apprehensive about her beauty
because it draws unwanted attention.
When her Persona awakens, it’s as Carmen
from the famous opera, a fierce femme fatale
who uses her penchant for seduction to deadly
effect.
Effectively, this transforms Ann’s appearance
from a liability into a strength.
Another Jungian term is Shadow or the psychological
aspects which the conscience self is unaware
of and would rather not acknowledge.
In the game, Shadows serve as the enemies.
Most are generic, but the bosses are Shadows
specific to certain characters.
But the game designers didn’t just look
to Jung for their worldbuilding.
His ideas are equally represented in the gameplay
mechanics as well.
The way Shadows and Personas are grouped reflects
Jung’s conception of archetypes.
Per Jung, “The term 'archetype' is often
misunderstood as meaning certain definite
mythological images or motifs, but.
... The archetype is a tendency to form such
representations of a motif—representations
that can vary a great deal in detail without
losing their basic pattern.”
So the Personas aren’t themselves part of
the Collective Unconscious that everyone inherits.
No one is born with the idea of Odin in their
head.
But they do have part of their mental space
sequestered off for the idea of Senex, the
generic Wise Old Man, and this idea is given
form through characters such as Odin, Baal,
and Thoth, who are all grouped together in
the game’s organization.
To capture a Shadow, Joker must find some
point of commonality with it.
That is, he must recognize it as being a part
of himself.
Similarly confronting and recognizing one's
own shadows is a distinctive aspect of Jung’s
process of individuation.
Once he’s moved it from the dark parts of
his psyche into the light of consciousness,
Joker can then equip that Shadow as a Persona.
But there’s another gameplay use for Personas
that better exemplifies the Jungian concept.
As Joker converses with important people called
Confidants - his bond with them strengthens.
Each of these has a particular archetype that
most closely exemplifies their personality.
By equipping a Persona belonging to the same
archetype before conversing with a Confidant,
Joker forges his friendship with them faster
since they’re recognizing something of themselves
in him.
This is reflective of Jung’s idea that we
wear different personas for different people,
choosing to share one side of ourselves with
friends, another with family, and another
with coworkers.
Even more Jungian is the Phantom Thieves entire
modus operandi.
They enter their mark’s psyche and steal
whatever the individual treasures so much
that it’s twisted their desires and distorted
their perception of reality, and always end
up confronting the target’s Shadow.
After this treasure is stolen and the Shadow
defeated, the individual undergoes a dramatic
change of personality.
This can be seen as akin to psychotherapy.
Despite stylizing themselves as thieves, their
goal is to effect psychological and moral
improvement in the subject, albeit less talking
on a couch to defeat inner demons and more
slashing them with samurai swords.
Given all of this - the consonance between
the worldbuilding, story, and the gameplay
mechanics all around this one unifying motif
- we’ve absolutely got to give Persona’s
use of Jungian Psychology a certified “Deep.”
Part 2 - Esoteric Tarot
The game continues its Jungian motifs with
the use of the Tarot to organize elements
such as Shadows, Personas, and Confidants
according to the archetypes found in the cards.
Jung himself acknowledged the Tarot as containing
compelling archetypal imagery: He wrote, “It
also seems as if the set of pictures in the
tarot cards were distantly descended from
the archetypes of transformation…”
Tarot began back in the 15th century as a
deck for playing card games.
In addition to the traditional four suits
- a.k.a. the Minor Arcana - it included twenty-two
trump cards - the Major Arcana.
It wasn’t until the late 18th century that
it began to be used for occult purposes, of
which you’re probably most familiar with
Cartomancy, or divining the future by drawing
cards.
But apart from fortune telling, the tarot
was also incorporated into occult schools
of thought, with each card taking on multitudes
of meaning, such as each of the Major Arcana
corresponding to one of the twenty-two letters
of the Hebrew alphabet and the twenty-two
paths in the Kabbalah’s Tree of Life, or
the four suits of the Minor Arcana corresponding
to the four classical elements and the four
letters of the tetragrammaton.
The use of the Tarot as a set of symbols became
known as Esoteric Tarot, to distinguish it
from its primary purpose as playing cards.
The order of the Major Arcana also tells a
story, known as the Fool’s Journey, that
is seen as both the story of each individual
soul and the history of the universe as a
whole.
Persona 5’s most successful application
of Esoteric Tarot is in structuring its Confidants
system around the Fool’s Journey.
Joker’s own journey begins when he meets
Igor, the Confidant associated with Arcana
0, “Le Meat,” a.k.a.
The Fool.
In Esoteric Tarot, The Fool is at the first
step on a path towards self-realization, with
that path taking him through the subsequent
cards of the Major Arcana.
This is reflected in Joker’s need to maximize
his rank with all of his Confidants - each
of whom is explicitly linked to one of the
Major Arcana, and whose own side-story teaches
Joker the lessons of their associated card.
It’s not enough for him to simply beat the
final boss.
Like The Fool, he has to achieve enlightenment
in the way prescribed by Esoteric Tarot in
order to unlock the game’s True Ending.
Which Arcana the Confidants belong to often
reflects the role they play in the narrative.
Occasionally the game makes a particularly
appropriate connection regarding what Arcana
a character belongs to and which Persona they
manifest.
Makoto’s Arcana is “Le Papesse,” traditionally
associated with the legendary Pope Joan, the
very same as Makoto’s initial Persona, Johanna.
But more often the game makes a surface level
association between a character’s Arcana
and their personality.
Ann’s Arcana is “L'Amoureux” (the Lovers),
primarily because she is the first love interest
available in the game and the object of desire
to multiple male characters.
Futaba of “L'Ermite” literally hermits
herself away in her room.
Chihaya of the “Roue de Fortune” is herself
a tarot reading fortune teller.
And Tae Takemi’s work in the medical field
places her in proximity to death (her’s
being the card with no name, a.k.a. “La
Mort”).
This last one reveals how Atlus’s understanding
of Esoteric Tarot can be a bit shallow.
As the Thirteenth Arcana is associated not
with literal death but is rather symbolic
of endings and change.
In some cases the surface level connection
comes at the cost of a deeper one.
Haru’s final Persona, Astarte (of the Empress
Arcana), is specifically called “the Queen
of Heaven in the Bible.”
This naturally compares her with Mary, whom
the Catholics affirm is the Regina Coeli - the
Queen of Heaven.
However, Arthur Edward Waite - who co-created
the most famous Esoteric Tarot deck - contrasts
the Empress with Mary as the Queen of Heaven,
saying the empress is associated with Mary
only as Refugium Peccatorum - the Refuge of
Sinners and an earthly Garden of Eden.
According to him The Empress is very specifically
not a heavenly figure.
The game gets it backwards.
This is hardly nitpicking.
Esoteric Tarot is interesting specifically
because its imagery and structure invite systemization
with diverse schools of thought like the Jewish
Kabbalah and the Catholic corpus doctrinae.
In getting the meanings mixed-up, Persona
5 doesn’t quite justify structuring its
systems around the Tarot.
The game is obviously interested in Tarot
for its esoteric associations as well as its
Jungian ones, but fails to engage with the
esotericism in any real meaningful ways.
The fact that the game follows the Tarot of
Marseilles, an older deck more associated
with card games, rather than the Rider-Waite
deck, which was specifically constructed to
convey esoteric symbolism, certainly evidences
this.
While the Fool’s Journey of the Confidants
system and one or two of the characters’
associated Arcana are somewhat deep, for the
most part Persona 5’s use of Tarot is kinda
Dumb.
Part 3 - Ethical Systems and Moral Realism
But Persona 5 is also structured to make a
moral argument.
The story is built around heisting a few major
Palaces - parts of the Metaverse that have
been warped by the distorted perception of
a sinful individual.
Because the Phantom Thieves suck at sneaking,
all their heists culminate in a climatic boss
battle against the Palace’s owner, or at
least their Shadow.
These big bads are based on the Seven Deadly
Sins, with each of their Palaces explicitly
named after one of the vices.
1.
Kamoshida, like many dudes who coach high
school girls’ athletics, is pervy; his Palace
is the Castle of Lust.
Inside it his Shadow looks like Asmodeus,
who, according to theologian Peter Binsfeld,
is the Prince of Hell associated with Lust.
2.
Madarama is an artist that uses other people’s
works to promote his own fame, so his Palace
is the Museum of Vanity.
3.
Kaneshiro is a corpultant crime boss who hungers
for more and more money from those he extorts.
That may sound like greed, but his palace
is the Bank of Gluttony, a theme reinforced
not only by his rotundity, but by the Beelzebub-like
appearance of his Shadow, that being the demon
Binsfeld connected to Gluttony.
4.
Futaba’s anger at herself for apparently
causing her mother’s death results in her
Palace being the Pyramid of Wrath.
5.
Okumura is a businessman who envisions his
employees as robots existing only to labor
for him, his Palace being the Spaceship of
Greed.
He isn’t interested in money solely, but
wealth in all its various expressions - i.e.,
mammon, so it’s appropriate that the same
demon is also the name of his Shadow, again
following Binsfeld’s list.
6.
Niijima is a prosecutor who’s envious of
her colleagues’ win records and thus willing
to do anything to get a conviction.
Her Palace is the Casino of Envy, where the
house always wins, and her Shadow - per Binsfield
- is Leviathan.
7.
Shido is a politician who, when he tried to
force himself on a woman and Joker saved her,
had Joker charged with assault.
His express aim as Prime Minister is to screw
over unwashed masses while profiting his chosen
few.
You know, a typical politician.
His Palace is the Cruiser of Pride, traditionally
the deadliest sin.
8.
Humanity as a whole is responsible for such
intellectual and moral laziness that they
collectively have a distorted perspective
of reality, leading to the public Palace known
as Mementos, a.k.a. the Prison of Sloth.
And no, we didn’t forget how to count.
The Seven Deadly Sins have as their antecedent
the monk Evagrius Ponticus’ Eight Evil Thoughts,
until Pope Gregory I subsumed Vainglory under
Pride.
The ordering of the villains’ appearances
conforms roughly to the severity of the sins
per traditional Catholic understanding.
This is seen most vividly in Dante’s Purgatorio.
Dante’s ordering was Lust, Gluttony, Avarice,
Sloth, Wrath, Envy, Pride.
This is essentially the same as the order
of the Palaces in Persona, with one important
difference: Persona moves Sloth to the final
slot, suggesting that Sloth is properly the
deadliest sin.
In addition to the inherent evil of their
signature sin, the villains are also ordered
with respect to their sphere of influence,
with greater influence allowing for a greater
severity to their transgressions.
Whereas Kamoshida’s influence is limited
only to Shujin Academy, Madarame has influence
over the entire art community, Kaneshiro over
a wide swath of the criminal underworld, and
Okumura and Shido on a national stage as captains
of business and politics, respectively.
The final boss is Yaldabaoth, a gnostic name
for the creator of the world, because it wouldn’t
be a proper JRPG if you didn’t kill God
at the end.
And being God, his influence extends over
the whole of humanity.
The name Yaldabaoth comes from the Apocraphon
of John: “Now the archon who is weak has
three names.
The first name is Yaltabaoth, the second is
Saklas, and the third is Samael.”
This connects Yaldabaoth with the penultimate
boss, Shido, whose shadow is Samael and Joker
himself, as Saklas means “fool” a reference
back to Joker being on the Fool’s Journey.
Now the narrative progresses in one other
interesting way.
The villains are ordered roughly according
to which system of ethics their supposed authority
derives from.
Kamoshida and Madarame are both adults in
a position of authority preying on high schoolers
- Kamoshida by hitting on literal jailbait,
and Madarame by stealing his students’ artwork.
Neither’s actions align with any ethical
theory.
Both simply presume that their age gives them
natural authority.
This is pretty much the first ethical framework
any individual operates under— to listen
to those older than us.
Kaneshiro’s self-loathing at his own perceived
weakness leads him to operate under the theory
that might-makes-right, and to build a criminal
enterprise to compensate.
All of these are what psychologist Lawrence
Kohlberg in his stages of moral development
categorized as “pre-conventional.”
Such moral attitudes are marked by their “deference
to superior power or prestige” as opposed
to principled moral reasoning.
Alternatively, as a prosecutor, Sae Niijima
occupies Kohlberg’s fourth stage of moral
development, a “conventional” category
in which the law itself is the foundation
for morality- whether or not the law is actually
just.
Shido and Yaldabaoth represent Kohlberg’s
“post-conventional” stages of moral development.
As Prime Minister, Shido’s authority derives
from the consent of the governed.
This is Kohlberg’s fifth stage, in which
laws are malleable based on the will of the
masses.
Kohlberg’s sixth stage is that of universal
ethical principles - right and wrong are the
same for all people at all places at all times,
regardless of man-made laws.
One permutation of a universal ethical principle
is Divine Command Theory - the idea that the
foundation of morality is whatever God says
is right or wrong.
As a stand-in for God, Yaldabaoth is representative
of this type of moral reasoning.
In fighting all these foes, the Phantom Thieves
are not merely opposing the deadly sins themselves,
but also the various ethical frameworks to
which society has subscribed.
And we think this is why the structure of
the game imputes Sloth as the deadliest sin
of all.
Humanity’s sloth has made it intellectually
and morally lazy.
Humanity has abdicated the hard work of moral
decision making to these various ethical systems,
and the even harder work of actually being
morally active members of society, to those
few individuals running the various spheres
of influence - and unfortunately they’ve
not been particularly moral.
The Thieves, while far from immoral or amoral,
don’t neatly conform their ethical hand-wringing
to any prescribed ethical theories.
This is what differentiates them from the
slothfulness of the masses under the sway
of Yaldabaoth.
Throughout all of the heists cumulatively,
the Thieves go through an ethical process
that French philosopher Jacques Derrida described
as “undecidability.”
Essentially, all moral decisions come down
to deciding between taking actions based on
a moral framework or rejecting those actions
for any reason ranging from not feeling like
it to distrust for the moral frameworks at
play.
For instance The Thieves consistently reject
the justifications for the laws that Sae Niijima
blindly enforces.
And even when the rules seem to have a foundation,
such as Shido’s democratic mandate or Yaldabaoth’s
divine commands, such rote formulae won’t
necessarily apply to individual circumstances.
Thus, according to Derrida, all moral decision
making is undecidable by prescribed ways of
thinking.
“A decision that did not go through the
ordeal of the undecidable would not be a free
decision, it would only be the programmable
application or unfolding of a calculable process.”
Only by exerting great moral and intellectual
effort - by continually undergoing Derridean
“undecidability” time and again throughout
their careers - are our heroes able to avoid
the deadly sin of Sloth.
But while the Phantom Thieves avoided slothfulness
themselves, by being the only ones to take
on these various systems, they become a moral
crutch who everyone else outsources their
decision-making to.
So whether it’s the Thieves, or Sae and
Shido, the end result is the same.
This is why Yaldabaoth remains as powerful
as ever even after Shido is defeated.
At first, this seems to be an example of the
game’s mechanics coming into conflict with
its narrative – the story is saying that
society itself has to overcome its moral lethargy,
but by virtue of being a game that can only
come about by decisions you as the player
make – the NPCs never make a real choice
and continue to avoid confronting undecidability,
and continue being slothful.
. Hiding the True Ending behind maxing out
all the Confidants is a smart solution to
this problem.
That is to say that in the True Ending all
of the NPCs who help with the final victory
have gone through the same ethical challenge
as The Phantom Thieves.
Despite challenging such ethical frameworks,
by framing the decision to destroy Yaldabaoth
as unambiguously right, Persona 5 ultimately
affirms moral realism.
Even if no one ethical system can fully articulate
what makes good right and evil wrong, good
and evil are very much real.
It condemns the moral nihilism of the game’s
foil, Goro Akechi.
This is a departure from Derrida, who rejects
the notion that we’re ever approaching a
True Ethics, and claims Undecidability is
the whole of the matter, but the game says
it’s only a step toward the truth of Right
and Wrong.
Thankfully, the game is more clear than real
life in assuring you that you did the right
thing, mainly by rewarding you with an anime
waifu on Valentine's Day.
For balancing the complication of ethical
systems with an affirmation of moral realism
and giving as extensive an examination of
moral wrongdoing as Dante, Persona 5 is as
“Deep” as the Ninth Circle of Hell.
But tell us what you think, Wisecrack.
Are we being too much like fortune-tellers,
reading too much into what’s just not there?
Or did we successfully infiltrate your cognition
and force a change of heart as to
how you feel about Persona 5?
Let us know in the comments below.
Big shout out to all our awesome patrons.
Don’t forget to subscribe